AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT
GAME, NUGE IT OR LOSE IT!
TED NUGENT, THE
UBER-CONSERVATIVE DADCORE ROCK
STAR AND FREQUENT KID ROCK
BLOWJOB-GIVER...
PLEASE DON'T SHOOT ME!
WE'RE JUST MAKING JOKES.
UH, BAWITDABA DA BANG A DANG...
I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY,
I'M SORRY!
NO, YOU STOP IT!
THEY MADE ME DO IT!
I'M SORRY!
I'M NARCISSISTIC AND STARVED FOR
ATTENTION!
THEY ENCOURAGED ME!
ANYWAY, THIS PIECE OF (BLEEP)
HAS RECOVERED LONG ENOUGH
FROM THE TRENCH MOUTH...
HE'S PROBABLY A NICE GUY...
(CHUCKLES)
HE'S RECOVERED FROM THE TRENCH
MOUTH HE CONTRACTED WHILE
HUNTING PANDAS WITH HIS HOMEMADE
FLAMETHROWER TO DEFEND DONALD
TRUMP.
HE TOLD WIBX RADIO WHAT HE
THINKS OF REPUBLICAN DEBATE
MODERATOR MEGYN KELLY, WHO WENT
AFTER TRUMP FOR SEXIST REMARKS,
SAYING, "I OFTEN JUST TURN ON
FOX TO LOOK AT HER, SOMETIMES
WHEN I'M LOADING MY MAGAZINES.
AND I USUALLY SIT NAKED ON THE
COUCH, DROPPING HOT BRASS ON MY
STUFF."
I WAS RIGHT.
HE'S A PIECE OF (BLEEP).
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A LINE FROM HIS
EROTIC NOVEL, 50 NECKS OF RED.
THIS...
THIS WHOLE INCIDENT DEFIES MATH
BECAUSE TRUMP AND NUGENT ARE
NEGATIVE AND THAT SHOULD EQUAL A
POSITIVE, BUT, IN REALITY, IT
JUST CREATES A DOUCHEBAG BLACK
HOLE.
SO, COMEDIANS, NOW THAT WE KNOW
THE NUGE WATCHES FOX NAKED WHILE
LOADING A GUN, WHAT ELSE DO YOU
THINK HE DOES ON HIS COUCH?
LET'S FIND OUT IN 60 SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
CRAIG ROWIN.
>> TRYING TO REMEMBER ONE OF HIS
SONGS THAT ISN'T "CAT SCRATCH
FEVER."
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
JANET.
>> METH.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
RICH.
>> CORNROWS HIS PUBES?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
YOU SAID THAT LIKE YOU WERE
ASKING ME FOR PERMISSION.
(BELL DINGS)
CRAIG.
>> BINGE-WATCHING "CAKE BOSS."
I JUST HAPPEN TO KNOW HE LOVES
THAT SHOW.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
CRAIG.
>> PROBABLY DOG (BLEEP)ING.
>> HARDWICK: POIN... (LAUGHS)
POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
"I CAUGHT THIS DOG WITH MY BARE
HANDS.
THAT'S MY WAY.
NOW I GET TO (BLEEP) IT."
>> AS LONG AS HE USES EVERY PART
OF IT.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
>> AW...
YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: JANET.
>> I WANT TO SAY FALLS ASLEEP
WITH A LIT CIGARETTE IN HIS
MOUTH AND BURNS TO DEATH, I
HOPE.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
(BELL DINGS)
POINTS. RICH FULCHER.
>> WORKS ON HIS MUSICAL, "CAT
SCRATCH SATURDAY NIGHT FEVER."
(GROANING)
WHAT?
A GROAN'S AS GOOD AS A LAUGH,
PEOPLE!
(BUZZER SOUNDS)
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, I'LL
GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT.